guys I have a bit of an announcement to
make right now okay this is a bit of an
announcement if you were watching coffee
break videos be aware that Dan Locke is
watching he's watching you like a hawk
and Locke likes to say that his haters
spend all their time thinking about him
I noticed a lot of they're the haters
most of the time they are the the
nameless faceless right where they hide
behind the computers they talk [ __ ] they
made up [ __ ] that's just what they do
they spend so much time because you can
see it takes effort yeah let's talk
about effort dance let's talk about
those keyboard warriors because Dan
Locke actually has been spending a lot
more time on us that we've been spending
on him in fact he has a dedicated either
he himself does this or he has dedicated
staff reading all our comments on our
videos and he actually bans everyone who
who comments positively about coffee
Zillah here check this out look this is
this is a message I got from one of
Dan's students he was he received a
community ban with the offending comment
right here community ban because he look
at this this is crazy it come has come
to our attention that you made comments
in support of a defamatory content
regarding our brand this is against
community rules for this reason you have
been banned from this program and future
programs of Dan Locke that's something
he paid for that's something this guy
paid for and he got banned from it
because he made he committed the sin of
talking bad about seafood look guys you
don't talk bad about seafood okay you
don't even think bad about seafood
seafood knows you better watch out you
better not cry you better not made bad
comments about HTC I'm telling you why
Dan Locke is watching he's watching
everything you do he knows if you've
been naughty or nice look at this look
at this hi Dylan
different guy different guy okay he's
watching everything I am lark is
watching you guys as you support the
channel as you support everyone you know
knowing about the to dance of the world
as you support you know
real testimonials coming out people like
Dylann are getting banned for supporting
this look at this look this hi Dylan is
a courtesy message and they linked his
what he said here's another guy here is
another guy they took they said what he
did wrong look he all this guy said was
coffee Zilla is woke he didn't even say
that dan lock is bad he said coffee
Zilla is whoa and by the way guys
I'm very woke I'm about as awake as it
gets guys and what I'm awake to is that
Dan lock is feeling pressure he's
feeling under the gun so don't comment
on my videos if you were a student of
Dan until we figure out some better way
till he stops reading all my comment cuz
you'll get banned and I don't want you
to get banned
anyway it's gotten pretty bad out there
be careful you guys you're being watched
if you're in Dan's course Dan is
monitoring you he's monitoring what you
do you can't save it no no words Coffee
zilla's woke no no no no no no anyways
I'm just glad I live in America a place
where you can say coffee Zilla is
welcome and not have these Canadians
coming down on you see you guys next
Friday
[Music]